R kort, bis ich replace,
bekomme ich drowned,
fremst sätt,
Bla bla bla,
da liegt aber גם geholt.
Es ist Wasser,
das hat tanks in83 Aluminodium eingeholt.
Ein Arbeit wird das Ruhe verlainsiteit.
Mehr im Lautestiet.
Tamam.
Accurlements.
Lach sind nicht
da
Sie hat 10 bis 12 Zentimeter Vorlauf, manchmal auch 15 Zentimeter und diesen Vorlauf brauchen wir für den Beschleunigten.
Zubeilgen wir für die Karte nach vorne unten geneigt und hinten die Hinterkante etwas höher.
Und wenn wir gerade auskriegen und wir schauen immer nach oben, dann ist unsere Bremse nach hinten ausbaufend.
Macht so einen richtigen Bogen und das muss sein, oder?
Also bei mir nämlich den Beschleunigten Flug haben, ist dann die Bremse hinten gespannt.
Und die Bremse dürfen auf den Grund nicht ziehen im Beschleunigten Flug,
denn wenn wir jetzt noch zusätzlich die Bremse ziehen,
erzeugt das in dem Moment hier kurzzeitig mehr auftrieb,
in der Schirmkönne frontaleinklappen.
Einzeitig, ein Klau kann man es auch nicht sagen, auf jeden Fall ein Klapp gefahr,
deutlich erhöht, und aus dem Grund tut man nicht mehr Steuern mit,
in den Beschleunigten Flug.
So, können wir das nicht mehr,
mit Steuern.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Jetzt,
hat da bisher die Bremse so,
äh, in der Hand,
und das ist aber gerade beim Termik fliegen oft das Problem,
dass man mit dem Bremsen irgendwo da unten ziemlich tief arbeiten muss.
Oder bei starker Termik muss man einmal stärker bremsen.
Das heißt, da ist dann der Arbeitsbereich über längere Zeitraum
sehr sehr Kraftaufwendig.
Und deshalb gehen viele Piloten hin und verkürzten sozusagen diesen Bremsweg,
indem sie die Bremse anders halten.
Wir haben den sogenannten Franzosengriff.
Die Franzosen gehen dort oft, nicht alle,
aber viel beginnt durch den Bremskräftuch
und halten jetzt diese kleine Bremsleine,
zwischen alten diese Bremsleine, zwischen Zeigefinger und Daumen.
Man hat durch das ein sehr gutes Gespür.
Man hat die Bremse auch ein bisschen verkürzt,
und sie haben gesehen, dass er nicht den Notschirm auslösen konnte.
Also, könnte es wirklich an dem liegen,
dass man da nicht mehr aus den Bremskräftuch herauskommt.
Das heißt, wenn man das gern machen möchte,
dann kann man das wirklich machen,
indem man einfach den Daumen draußen lässt.
Und so kommt man doch schneller aus diesem Glück heraus.
Die Ungarn, das gibt den Ungarngriff,
die Ungarn haben dann gesagt moment,
das hat sich schon zu riskant.
Wir wollen aber die Bremsleine trotzdem zwischen Zeigefinger und Daumen behalten.
Und deshalb haben die Ungarn oder sind die Ungarn da zu hingegangen
und dann haben die Bremse einfach so hoch.
So kann man natürlich jederzeit loslassen und den Notschirm greifen.
Aber die Gefahr ist auch größer,
dass wir die Leine mal wirklich ausversehen.
Dann braucht man wieder einen Moment,
dass man die gepackt hat.
Von dem her ist jetzt für mich nicht unbedingt eine Variante.
Quellen wir jetzt nicht persönlich?
Wir gehen dazu her und verkürzen die Bremse wirklich extrem.
Also wir nehmen diese 10 bis 12 Zentimeter Wert auf die nehmen wir raus,
indem das mit die Bremse ganz normal am Steg in der Hand behalten.
Und so nach außen hin eine sogenannte Weglung machen.
Seht da was, als ich Drehse nach außen hin.
Und jetzt führe ich diese Bremsleine hier so am Handballen vorbei.
Und kann sie locker am Zeigefinger zwischen Zeigefinger und Daumen in der Hand behalten.
Habt sehr gutes Gespür für den Schirm.
Und habe jetzt einen sehr kurzen Steuerweg.
Das heißt, ich arbeite jetzt nur noch hier.
Und durch das ist es halt viel weniger Kraft aufwendig.
Ich habe eben einen Kürzer und Weg, spürt den Schirm besser,
weniger Kraft aufwendig und der Vorteil kann die Wirkung jederzeit wieder rausnehmen.
Oder wenn ich einen Wert brauche,
dann mache ich noch mehr an.
Stoll, wo ich spürsweise, R-Shim, zwei Möwen.
Okay, also sehr ein großer Vorteil.
Und vergewisse mein Lüber.
Ohne sehr gute Wahrheit.